Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
If you're a regular viewer of my channel,
you've probably heard it be reiterated a few times by now that Columbus was not
the first confirmed person from the old world to reach the Americas.
It was the vikings.
However,
what I haven't talked about as frequently are some speculations about people
that may have made it to the Americas in between Columbus and the vikings or
even before the Vikings and today I want to talk about one such theory.
Is it possible that I'll need decades before Columbus reached the Americas,
the Chinese landed in the same area.
This might sound like a conspiracy theory,
but there's actually an interesting amount of debate over the subject which we
are going to explore today.
So as I said,
there are multiple claims of people reaching a new world from the old world or
even vice versa before Columbus.
I will look at a number of these claims in the future.
I might even dedicate a whole video to some of them,
but the theory with China region,
the Americas stands out among them because it's something that was completely
possible for the Chinese civilization at the time to have accomplished.
The main theory which we're seeking to prove or disprove was made popular by the
book written by Gavin Menzies called 1421 the year China discovered America.
1421 is of course,
71 years before Columbus landed in the Caribbean.
So before we explore this claim,
let's look at what was going on in Shyna slightly before 1421 and early 15th
century China,
the Ming Dynasty was beginning to take root in the country.
It was replacing the yuan dynasty,
which was a remnant of the Mongolian empire.
The young Lee emperor whose name was Judy,
wanted to expand China's raisins in a manner of speaking,
and he did much of this militarily.
He firstly kind of reconstructed the Great Wall of China,
but then turned his attention to China's naval power.
The main aspect of this naval buildup was what is referred to as the treasure
fleet,
which will be sent on the treasure voyages.
Leading the treasure fleet was Admiral Jang,
Huh,
who was Chinese but was raised a Muslim and was brought into the Chinese
imperial courts.
The purpose of this expedition was not merely curiosity or anything like that.
There was a clear intent with the treasure fleet to lay the grounds for China's
expansion into what the emperor envisioned as a kind of superpower,
which is very relevant to the question of potential Chinese discovery of the
Americas.
The Chinese,
we're not screwing around.
To further demonstrate that China had complete potential to have discovered the
Americas.
Here is a comparison between one of Columbus's ships and one of Jang has ships.
Columbus commanded 88 men and three ships is young,
has commanded about 28,000 men on 300 ships.
China was basically on par,
if not ahead of Europe technologically specifically with regard to navigational
technology and understanding and such things.
These ships carried food to last for years and even if they began to run out,
had soil on the ships for the purpose of growing more.
They had weaponry and horses is fleet had the potential to sail around the whole
world and fight battles and such things along the way and fight battles.
The fleet did in fact do.
The purpose of the treasure voyages,
as I said,
was not arbitrary or undefined.
The Chinese wanted to not only expand commerce,
but to dominate it.
They not only wanted to open diplomatic relations with other people,
that's what they wanted to establish a Gemini over them.
Essentially,
they want it to assert Chinese dominance and authority across the world.
They would flaunt their wealth and power through the gifts that they brought for
unreal has,
but what also quite forcefully demand tribute from them as well.
If you are the ruler of a small kingdom which they visited,
you would not want these people knocking on your door because with the backbone
that they had from this massive fleet,
resisting their demands was not an easy option between 1405 and 1433 young.
How would lead seven expeditions across the world with these intentions laid out
to him by the emperor.
Here is a map of those voyages.
As you can see,
the fleet spent most of their time in Asia and Indonesia and India and things
like that,
but also voyage the Middle East where it's worth mentioning.
Junge [inaudible] was able to make his pilgrimage to Mecca and even went along
the coast of east Africa,
possibly as far south as Mozambique.
That is what is agreed upon officially by historians.
There's plenty of evidence to believe this much.
Some historians like Gavin Menzies,
however,
claim that he kept going past Mozambique,
reaching West Africa,
the Americas,
Australia,
and finishing it off with having circumnavigated the whole planet.
The farther he has claimed to have gone.
However,
the weaker that the evidence is,
but what evidence is there?
Menzies claims that the Chinese sailed around Africa and then reach South
America and the Caribbean then swung around to places like modern Ahla where the
ink and empire was and Modern Day California messy theory is not the only one
worth talking about.
However,
and we will consider the notion of China's simply sailing eastward to California
and Mexico.
In that Matt evidence initially rested on the record that Europeans did not say
a blindly into the unknown when they traveled westward.
They were going off maps which unfortunately no longer exist,
which may have outlined certain parts of the Americas.
Menzies originally believed that these maps were made by Portuguese explorers
but soon found this to not be true what the rest of Europe,
the Muslim world,
Africa and such places being unlikely candidates.
He concluded that the maps must've been Chinese and correlated them to this
magnificent treasure voyage which occurred at a similar time.
Menzies Theory is reinforced by certain archeological finds,
certain artifacts found in north and South America like jewelry,
beads are pieces,
coins,
etc. Resemble those which would be consistent with the Chinese at a time.
However,
no artifacts are a significant enough for a confirmation.
Some artifacts which are surely Chinese have been shown to originate from a much
later time such as the palace Verdes stones discovered in California.
Their discovery led some to question if the Chinese had not been here long
before 1421 believing that the came from around the year 500 however they have
been shown to come from.
Actually it turns out the 18 hundreds some artifacts from this time period
cannot be confirmed to be Chinese or at least even influenced by the Chinese
such as drawings of what you might interpret as horses made by native tribes in
Peru from around this time period,
which the Chinese would have almost definitely exposed native Americans do had
they truly landed on the continent.
However,
the animals in question are ambiguous and very likely not actually horses.
Beyond this,
the evidence is actually very weak.
As you can see,
there are no artifacts which pointed definite contact between the Chinese and
native Americans in the 15th century.
As for the maps which I mentioned,
many are vague and none confirmed the hypotheses.
Most historians are not convinced and some even accused of maps of being
forgeries which were created to support Menzies theory.
Gavin Menzies then goes off the deep end with his theory,
despite the lack of evidence for even the core of it,
claiming that the Incan empire was ruled by Chinese military officials and that
Moctezuma the second,
the famous ruler of the Aztec Empire was actually Chinese and believe that when
Cortez landed in the Americas,
it was his grandfather making a return.
There is no evidence for this.
It makes no sense and thus there's no reason to believe it.
However,
that little fantasy doesn't negate all possibility that the Chinese landed in
the America is altogether.
Yet historians still need the very major issue of the fact that there is not
evidence as a port.
This settled especially because in their view there most definitely should be.
The signs of European influence in the Americas from the beginning are very
blatant.
The Vikings who landed in the Americas at least 400 years before the Chinese
here are purport to have still left obvious remnants of their voyages and
presence that we can still find today.
It is recorded in both native folklore and Viking history and you can actually
go to Canada and find all kinds of evidence that the vikings were indeed there
even if for only a short time.
Furthermore,
it's worth considering the issue of the lack of the crosspollination that
occurred when Europeans rich is saying that if society is that the Chinese are
said to have reached things like corn and tomatoes,
gold and silver and all kinds of things that the natives had would have been as
interesting to the Chinese as it was to the Europeans and the things the Chinese
would've had would've been as interesting to the natives as a thing so that the
Europeans had this transfer of resources and things did not take place,
at least on the scale that it did between Europeans and native Americans.
There are not only not any confirmed Chinese artifacts in the Americas,
but there are no records of Aztec gold or native American corn making their way
to China.
This seems to rule out the notion that the Chinese were active in the Americas
or even had a major interest in it.
However,
it still doesn't completely negate the possibility of Chinese discovery of the
Americas.
Remember that I said that the treasure fleets objective to expand China's power
and influence throughout the world,
it is possible that the Chinese perhaps landed in California or Chile or
somewhere like that,
but found the native populations.
It'd be two unremarkable to really focus on,
they already considered Indians,
Arabs,
Africans,
and Europeans to be inferior.
Barbarian People's,
even though they were civilized and thus one could conclude that they would have
thought less of the tribes of the new world who were and their view much less or
would have been in their view,
much less civilized and they have thus disregarded them.
However,
this is merely postulation.
Now,
evidence supports this possibility,
so it shouldn't affect that there is not much evidence to support this theory.
Be The nail in the coffin for it.
Well,
not exactly.
It's worth pointing out that a lot of the treader voyage and itself was lost to
history because the rulers which came after this time intentionally erased a
significant amount of it.
Why the Chinese abandoned their expansionist mentality.
They viewed barbarian forerunners with hostility and saw no purpose and
exploring the world any further,
preferring to focus on the domestic affairs with China and isolate themselves as
much as possible.
This being the case not only where the records of the treasure voyages a race,
but much less emphasis was placed on Chinese naval power because it was
unnecessary in their view.
Thus diminishing the opportunity for more voyages.
China had very few enemies over the sea and had only header tube and invaded
over the land.
Thus a navy or a strong navy at least was seen as unnecessary by the Chinese
government for quite a long time.
Actually,
many of the remnants from this age,
we're only accidentally discovered in the 1930s and the story is still being
pieced together because the story is still being pieced together.
Some historians still hold that the possibility of Chinese discovery of the
Americas is somewhere waiting to be found.
However,
as of yet,
both evidence and logical analysis of the events that we know for sure took
place.
Lead the answer to the question,
did the Chinese has covered the American's before Columbus as probably not and
even if they did this with only likely amounts of being a footnote in history,
bragging rights for the Chinese to say that they were the first.
I suppose you could say there's even less reason to believe that there was a
major impact from the discovery if it even took place.
Nevertheless,
we can still definitely imagine a scenario in which a Chinese not only
discovered the Americas but pursued their expansionist mentality they had in the
15th century the complete capability to give birth to a global empire.
Similar to the ones which are the Europeans constructed.
What if the Chinese had discovered the Americas and began colonies in the area?
How would this have changed?
World history,
the 18th century,
the 19th century,
the world wars,
the Cold War,
the modern day.
It's interesting to consider the possibilities of this alternative history.
I imagine this would have led to east versus West conflict very early on and the
Americas,
perhaps a war between Spain and China in the modern western United States and
perhaps later across the world,
given the Chinese hostility to foreigners,
I doubt the native Americans would have been dealt with better hand in this
alternate timeline.
However,
as for our history,
the likelihood is very slim that the Chinese made it to the American's before
Columbus.
However,
definitely worth exploring.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
I'd like to now take the opportunity to mention that I have created a fire of
learning patrion the link to which you may find in the comments section below.
There's no pressure to check it out.
Regardless of how you all respond,
I will give 100% of you guys and this channel no matter what.
However,
your support would absolutely provide an opportunity for the channels and grow
and become even better and rest assured any support given will be used for the
betterment and the pursuits of fire of learning.
I'll probably make a video talking about the Patriots specifically soon.
Mostly because I'm still working with it and I would appreciate absolutely your
guys' input on the subject,
but for now,
that's all I wanted to say.
For more videos like this and videos or many other subjects,
be sure to take out fire learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.